tara la rara disegni le cose lei ne
indovina allora look seppi è bravo alice
a lei scherza aderenza ai schiera è
iniziata la spada e là dei ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono fa vigente
ed oggi la voce mia partita siamo
ragazzi su un video particolare perché
c'è questo sito chiarissime di di
applicazioni o siti futuristici
non ho ancora provato una mazza però
chaos interactive greeting voodoo you
love e selena gomez
[Musica]
tara la rara
camminare
è la cosa più bella epica che io abbia
mai visto in tutta la mia vita
lightsaber escape vai disney fuga con
una spada laser un'esperienza pensata
per chrome non è vero non è possibile
che questo nuovo resto male ma che cazzo
è ma non è possibile mai luca bastardo è
una spada laser cazzo sono state calmi
non mi fate niente io tardo crepa già
fatta cosa sta succedendo specchi che
aspetta e calibrato male fermo calibra
telefono sono calibro sono tutto
calibrato 6 riprendi vai
cio fantasma cos'è ragazzi ma bellissimo
ai mori grecia a lei scherza aderenza a
rischiarla è iniziata la spada marte
sarebbe molto bello contrastarvi se
avesse ancora una spada cielo tutto
cazzuto herrman arti sul serio ora come
nuovo bene la spada con un vero
spadaccino
ma non mi dire proviamo tipo per questo
il primo bello
oddio carica e vabbè sono scemo ho
capito quindi devo passare i prossimi
chiarite non sono capaci di fare queste
cose di intelligenza non sono sveglio
fuori possono e vabbè alla madonna ci ho
fatto mica son fortissima per la madonna
che dava bellissimo come sboccare in tre
minuti siete ubriachi dopo una giornata
di festa e di alcol a manetta guardate
questo video porca eva il mio computer
sta implodendo ciao sono alice ciao
alice nuovo arresto ma le tue disegni le
cose lei ne indovina allora lops happy
bravo alice ha capito tutto a proviamo a
fare tipo una faccina normale vedere se
funziona
ap problema invece tipo quello incassato
bello fantastico suo disegno è in grande
il giusto e ora proviamo a fare falli
james miglia leggermente ave dai non è
così male città infinita lunch
experiment fatemi vedere voglio vederlo
fermi tutti il to play
cos'è sta roba che salvi le città
infinita che si genera tipo minecraft
passare che sbirciare le finestre vadalà
kate è bellissimo solo dire che la città
infinita che dovunque vado continuare ma
lei sono finiti dai palazzi era non è
finita a noi non è vero scherzavo va
bene sono fi e bellissimo sono proprio
contento poi andare avanti quanto cazzo
vuoi e continuerebbe all'infinito sta a
casa lampeggia cosa è successo a una
discoteca tutto l'edificio oppure c'è un
problema di fondo qua va beh la cosa
ragazzi perché dunque one million star
online star registra il project se
stanno dio
porca eva una palla di fuoco di un
milione di chilometri di diametro non
milione di terra e potrebbero entrare
qua dentro va bene con una distanza di
cento anni luce possiamo trovare 10.000
sistemi solari forchia dry e non trova
la fanta in frigo sorical juve stars
were divenne a questo quale hanno dato
cappella gliel'ha dato nome cappella
rocco la nascondeva a farmi cliccare se
voglio cliccare secondo me ragazzi se
continua a togliere lo zoom e andare
indietro trova in marocco ai ragazzi
facciamo il prossimo mi sembra carino
dal cos'è
va bene mi chiamarti in gara mi fa una
pippa rega cosa succede nel cervello
quando fa i compiti di matematica
ho cliccato per sbaglio sulla chiusura
della pagina dai ragazzi per me va bene
così
sono contento comunque il migliore in
assoluto il migliore se non fosse stato
perché il calibrato di merda al telefono
era la spada laser ma in assoluto era
bellissimo per ora vedo vi sia piaciuto
spero che avete imparato come usare la
spada soprattutto perché mica è una
figata che i ragazzi se vi è piaciuta
sul documento è un mi piace ai capace di
facebook che come nota trascrizione
censiti schifi ci vediamo al museo visto
bello ragazzi